Що робити, щоб затримка чи скасування авіарейсу
не зіпсували відпустку?
Все залежить від причини затримки, її тривалості та типу рейсу.
Останній гучний скандал стосувався українського лоукостера SkyUp,
який з авіафлотом у 8 літаків виконує
31 регулярний рейс  та 15 чартерних.
Через поломку одного з літаків
затримки торкнулися половини рейсів цієї авіакомпанії,
а деякі пасажири добу не могли вилетіти додому.
Якщо йдеться про технічну несправність
або навіть відсутність літака в аеропорту, то в цьому винна авіакомпанія.
Вона повинна максимально швидко вирішити проблему
або заплатити вам компенсацію.
Великі авіаперевізники мають на такі випадки резервні літаки,
і тому їхні рейси рідко затримуються більше, ніж на чотири години.
Проте може йтися і про обставини, які стаються не з вини авіакомпанії.
Наприклад, страйки, виверження ісланського вулкану,
масові безлади, несправності систем електропостачання чи зв'язку
в аеропортах тощо. У такому разі пасажирам
запропонують інший рейс або віддадуть гроші.
Але жодних компенсацій від авіаперевізників.
Гроші вам можуть сплатити страхові компанії,
якщо перед подорожжю ви застрахували свій переліт чи відпустку.
Проте поки в Україні це рідко хто робить.
Якщо рейс скасували за два тижні до поїздки і вас попередили,
то авіакомпанія просто віддасть вам гроші.
Проте якщо ви вже в аеропорту, а ваш авіарейс
скасували в останній момент, то сума компенсації
становить 135-650 доларів на одного пасажира -
залежно від дальності перельоту.
Якщо ж авіакомпанія швидко знайде вам альтернативний рейс
і ви чекатимете недовго, то вона має право
на 50% зменшити суму компенсації.
У разі не скасування, а затримки рейсу
послуги змученим пасажирам теж залежать від дальності польоту.
Так, авіакомпанія має забезпечити вас харчуванням і холодними напоями,
дасть можливість двічі подзвонити чи надіслати e-mail,
на відносно короткий рейс –
скажімо зі Львова у Мюнхен, Софію чи Ригу.
Або більше трьох годин,
якщо рейс середньої дальності - як з Одеси у Лондон чи Барселону.
Або якщо ви чекали понад 4 години
– з Києва в Нью-Йорк, Делі чи у Пекін.
Звичайно ж, якщо вам доводиться чекати одну чи більше ночей,
авіаперевізник має організувати готель та оплатити ночівлю.
Головне – зберігати спокій!
А також пильність: перед купівлею квитка уважно читати правила
та договір з авіаперевізником,
а вже коли почалися проблеми з вильотом, то документувати їх:
фотографувати табло з написом про затримку літака,
записувати розмови з туроператором чи турфірмою,
зберегти квиток та усі чеки, якщо вам довелося
самостійно купувати собі їжу та оплачувати готель.
А тоді - подавати скаргу і заяву на компенсацію.
Допомогти вам у цьому можуть з десяток приватних компаній,
які легко знайти в інтернеті –
вони спеціалізуються на вибиванні "авіавідшкодувань",
але за послуги візьмуть до 30-ти відсотків відвойованих коштів.
Проте варто пам’ятати: за законом авіакомпанії
компенсують лише переліт, готель та їжу.
А моральну шкоду є шанс вибити лише з туроператора.
Звісно, якщо ви знаєте про свої права і готові їх відстоювати.